يومًا بعد يوم يذهبون من منزل إلى
منزل.فريق المحققين الذين تم إرسالهم
من العاصمة
هؤلاء الرجال مكلفون بالبحث عن
حالات عنف جنسي
لم يتعرض أحد للاعتداء في هذه القرية ،
تخبرهن هؤلاء النساء ولكن كل منزل
عانى
عندما طردت القوات الروسية من
هذا  المنطقة في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر تركوا
وراءهم أثرًا من البؤس
على الطريق ،
طلبت امرأة مسنة لا تعوزها المساعدة.
سطور هي وحدها وتخشى
حسنًا أنها تريد دعوتنا لمعرفة
كيف تعيش
هذا ما تبقى من منزلها فقط
أيقوناتها الثمينة لم تمس
يا إلهي يا والدة الله تقول
أرجوك أبق ابني على قيد الحياة ودعني
أراه مرة أخرى
في مدينة تلو الأخرى في جميع أنحاء
منطقة هاريسون ، هذا ما
يبدو عليه النصر والأمر قاتم
تقريبًا أن كل منزل قد دمر بسبب
القتال العنيف وشهد الناس ندوبًا منذ
شهور.  احتلال روسي
في القرية التالية ،
تحدث المحققون مع تاتيانا البالغة من العمر 56 عامًا ،
واتفقنا على عدم تسمية القرية
أو إظهار وجهها لحماية
هويتها ، فأخذتنا إلى منزل شقيقها
حيث تقول إنها تعرضت للاغتصاب من قبل
جندي روسي.  في 26 أغسطس
، علَّقني بخزانة الملابس ولمسني
، أعني أنه مزق ملابسي
ووقعت في قبضته ، كان الأمر
صعبًا ومؤلماً بالنسبة لي ،
كنت أبكي وأتوسل إليه أن يتوقف
ولكن دون
جدوى وهل قال أي شيء  عندما انتهى الأمر
لا تخبر أحداً بأي شيء وإلا سيكون
الأمر أسوأ هذا كل ما قاله لي
ثم
تركني من الصعب جدًا علي
هل أخبرت زوجك بما
حدث نعم لم أخبر زوجي على
الفور ولكني قلت  سمع ابن عمي
وزوجي ،
أوه ،
نعم
، قال إنه كان يجب أن تخبرني
بالحقيقة لكنك بقيت صامتًا
لقد خجلت جدًا
من العار
عليه ، وربما لا يخجل إذا كان لا يزال
على قيد الحياة ، وأتمنى أن يكون هو وجميع أقاربه
قد ماتوا.
حتى نهاية يوم طويل
وعاطفي ، يزور الرجال القرية الأخيرة
في
قائمتهم ، وسوف يعودون إلى كييف
لتقديم النتائج التي توصلوا إليها ، لقد سجلوا
ستة ادعاءات بالاغتصاب في
الأسبوعين الماضيين
هنا ، يجب أن يكون
الأمر صعبًا.  يقول ألكسندر سيدرو إنه صعب نفسيًا لأنك
تفهم أن كل ضحية
حزينة جدًا ، لكن هذا
عمل مهم ، معظم الحالات التي يقولون إنها
لا يتم الإبلاغ عنها
مثل العديد من الفظائع التي وقعت في
ظل الاحتلال الروسي هنا ، فهي
تظل مخفية في الظلام كلاريسا وارد
منطقة كارسون في أوكرانيا.